hallo mein name ist luca und meine
lieben freunde ich denke ja darauf
instagram stunde des öfteren bei mir ne
story gesehen dass meine freundin jetzt
nicht so die aller aller allerbeste
autofahrerin ist was sagst du dazu
einfach frech ich habe auf jeden fall
gedacht dass peyton heute einen
führerschein test auffrischungskurs
situationen hier mal durchspielt haben
ja annähernd 40 fragen ich heiße alle
machen werden allerdings starten direkt
mit frage nummer eins der mir diese
situation der radfahrer komfort seite
ist ja fahrer des radfahrer ja jetzt
schon durchgefallen hier beim prüfer
einfach dazwischen geredet wie verhalten
sie sich hier richtig war den radfahrer
durch hupen b ich fahre vor dem
radfahrer oder c ich warte bis der
radfahrer abgebogen ist es ist es auf
jeden fall 10 ich wäre wahrscheinlich
eher b aber es ist sie
tragen oder 2 wie muss man sich bei
diesem
verkehrszeichen verhalten
ich glaube auch
nicht mehr so blöd wie du aussiehst wo
wir haben video war ich hab zu videos in
der fahrschule frigge hast gar nicht
gemacht die dann immer gleich aus aber
es zeigt dass jetzt gucken rückspiel
alles hinter uns her
und er wird an uns hat der fed relativ
neu auf
ok also wir verhalten uns richtig
erstens ich bremse kurze mit der
nachfolgende fahrer seine
geschwindigkeit reduziert ich
beschleunigung einen ausreichenden
sicherheitsabstand herzlich beide die
geschwindigkeit beim fahrer und
verwenden unverändert weiter
also du wirst auf jeden fall b ich werde
auf jeden fall ziehe ich mir aufgefallen
einig neben c und das ist richtig aber
ich war dran das ist ja auch zählt
nicht zuvor es ist wie dürfen sie in
ihrem pkw ein kleinkind mitnehmen
auf die frage nein wir machen das wie
man ein kleinkind pkw mit einer baby
tragetasche auf den hinteren sitzen mit
in einer für das kind geeigneten
rückhalteeinrichtungen mit prüfzeichen
er dass
das ist deutschland in einem satz
einfach wer parkt hier falsch hätten
entweder das weiße auto oder das
schwarze auto oder keiner der beiden er
weiß
ja sagt mir jetzt hier noch einmal ich
brauche führerscheine frisch weißt du
wir auch ein weißes auto fährt war
ziemlich identisch aussieht das ist so
schlecht
was endet mit diesem zeichen die
freiheitstraße das wollen wir gesagt ist
das spiegelei schild das ist das ist ein
spiegel ein video ich kenne das video
sogar
das war also an dass die teile die man
allerdings gesehen wird ich glaube schon
also ob es die alten sind weiß ich nicht
aber erst anderthalb jahren führerschein
gemacht
warum musst du hier jetzt verzögern
wegen des kindes du hast bisher anlauf
dass sieben von sieben fragen dass er
richtig beantwortet wie können sie
bereits bei der planung ihrer fahrten
zum umweltschutz beitragen plane
öffentliche verkehrsmittel statt des
eigenen fahrzeugs zu nutzen
fahrgemeinschaften anderen fahrzeug
nutzern bilden oder mehrere fahrer ziele
einer fahrt zusammenlegen nein ich alle
drei kannst auch alle drei antworten
würde ich auch sagen alle drei richtig
ich hätte nicht gedacht dass du so gut
bist tatsächlich was gilt unmittelbar
vor und auf zebrastreifen es darf nicht
gehalten werden das darf nicht geparkt
werden das darf nicht überholt werden
es ist schon crazy die müssen sie sich
in dieser straße verhalten wenn keine
person in der nähe sind da viel
schneller als schrittgeschwindigkeit
fahren ich darf nur mit
schrittgeschwindigkeit fahren oder ich
muss auch fußgänger besondere rücksicht
nehmen
b und c darf ich zu wenig
biss übel am rasieren altar wie können
sie beim fahren gefahrlos feststellen ob
die fahrbahn vereist ist bei ganz
langsamer fahrt bremsen kräftig gas
geben oder lenkung ruckartig hin und her
bewegen
was ich hätte jetzt angenommen ja
richtig gibst du nicht kräftig gas oder
längs ruckartig hin und her auf einer
glatten fahrbahn dieser frage geht es
jetzt um die lichthupe wo darf ich zu
benutzen um eine überhol absicht zu
äußern - bei dunkelheit außerorts bei
dunkelheit oder außerorts am tage also
du benutzt sie häufiger als ich
das wird ne ahnung ich benutze die
lichthupe
ich hätte gesagt das ist falsch
du darfst lichthupe außerorts benutzen
weil man rufe beide sind die automaten
mit k 180 oder so hörst du das natürlich
nicht mehr so richtig hier herrschte
sehr starker seitenwind von rechts wann
bist du beim überholen besonders
gefährdet beim fahrstreifenwechsel nach
dem überholen beim einfahren in den
windschatten des lkw oder beim
herausfahren aus dem windschatten des
lkw das ist auch falsch
ich heiße b und c ja logisch dass er
einmal eine wind veränderung wenn du
hinter dem lkw bist und wenn du sie das
vor dem lkw du wirst schon durchgefallen
nein das du festplätzen durch
worauf weist dieses verkehrszeichen
hinauf ein überholverbot das nach zwei
metern endet auf einer überholverbots
strecke von zwei metern länge oder auch
wenn überholverbot das in 200 metern
beginnt ja
das ist richtig
die höheren einsatzhorn welche fragen
müssen sie sich in diesem moment stellen
woher kommt das einsatzfahrzeug darf das
fahrzeug das einsatz von überhaupt
benutzen oder könnte das einsatzfahrzeug
durch mich behindert werden jetzt
einfach a und c gesagt es richtig machen
war dementsprechend direkt weiter mit
der nächsten frage dieses zeichen welche
fahrzeuge dürfen darf da dort sprachen
lernen welche fahrzeuge darf sie
überholen motorrad ohne beiwagen pkws
und motorräder mit beiwagen
solch ein kreuz
du musst auch motorräder mit beiwagen
überholt weil die geht es ja um autos
motorräder mit beiwagen sind fast so
breit wie ein auto okay das kann jeder
sein wie verhältst du dich bei diesem
verkehrszeichen ich weiß nicht was
bedeutet perfekt wenn ich rechts
abbiegen bin ich nicht wartepflichtig
was ich ware bremsbereit mit mäßiger
geschwindigkeit heran wo steht so ein
schild überhaupt bei uns
das ist wie ein stoppschild nur ohne das
zu stoppen muss aber ich habe das schon
ewig nicht mehr gesehen sind steht das
ist man eigentlich an fast jeder ecke
welche besonderheiten ergeben sich in
der kalten jahreszeit beim befahren von
allem so b auf jeden fall wegen nasser
laub sowie drei blabla ich hätte gesagt
kreuzfahrten ja auch noch was ich bin
durchgefallen
das wundert mich nicht aber ich war
überraschend gut es kann mir nicht mal
fragen mitrechnen dran
bremswege reaktionszeiten das kam mir
nicht mehr an das waren ja alles echt
eigentlich easy frage ich war auch echt
gut muss mal kurz überlegen
[Musik]
na ja
normal gerechnet
allerdings wird man der stelle freute
ich mich jetzt auch beenden wenn liebe
freunde wenn euch diese
führerscheinprüfung durch die nur
grandios ruhig gefallen müssen gerade
ist nur mit hält sich michael e doch du
erst auch durchgefallen das sind
gerüchte dass euch gefallen hat er das
auf jeden fall gerne einen daumen hoch
unter diesem video hier da boni main
kanal und klickt auf die glocke wenn ihr
weitere videos nicht verpassen wollt ich
verkaufe sein auto
[Musik]